Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
And welcome to MISTfortune.
A game where YOU are lost on an alien ship,
and apparently there is a deadly mist seeping through the doors
that's going to kill you at any moment, and apparently I'm gonna die,
Because everyone here is DEAD.
Except for me.... And maybe this, which contains some horrible gasses.
I'm not entirely sure-
Hello- *character has asthma* Ohhh! o.o
The fuck was that??
*looks around* Who's talkin to me? > .> <. <
Ohh, you're jiggly.... *3* Oooh~ Physics based, I like it
But why am I here??
Helloooo~?
Helloooo?
What, do I just have to walk into the "Mist"? And then DIE horribly?
*asthma again* Ow, ow, OW. Ookay, then... that's not right. - .-
Okay, so maybe I have to use this to suc- *sucky thing turns on* Whoa!
I do gotta use that to suck! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Ye- Oh, shit... uuuh... Okay?
But How do I direct it??
AAAgh.... *impersonating Arnold Schwarzenegger sounds*  Uhhgh- Ah! Oh, Okay!
Alright then, well that didn't work. Apparently I'm part of a clean up crew that all died! *thumbs up*
*crazed laughter*... We're dead....
Oh no, here too...
I'm low on health too... *reads* "Touch to fix power supply"-
Well if it was THAT easy, then why didn't you do it, you dick??
You just had to die, laying your head down by the seeping mists *trying to hide a chuckle*
Kay, open! :D
...
Alllrighty then! I did it- I think.... ">.>
Oh boy....
Ok...
Mist: "Are you the last crew member?"
Mark: @.@
*manly screams*AHHH, Okay, ah-FUCK! *magestic moose* eh-haha!
HeY!
Mist: "You're going nowhere... >:3 "
Oh-Hey, oh wey, oh wey, Oh.... Buddy, I don't want any, Buddy I don't want any, Buddy I don't want any! x<
*turns on sucky thing* Get sucked- GET SUCKED! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Mist: "A Trap? Seriously?"
Yeah!
Yeah, a trap! Seriously!
It's called my sucking trap! You get sucked, and then you die! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Alrigh-
Mist: *interrupts* "That wont work for long..."
Mark: @, @ Oh.....
No- *goes to turn sucky thing on* Ack! This is not a sucking trap!
It was a lie!
Ack, OPEN!
Mist: "Your desperation does not match my persistence..."
Ah, okay? "My desperation doesn't match your persistence??"
Mist: "Why are you running? :( "
I dunno, maybe you're trying to kill me??
Mist: "This didn't work for anyone...."
Eh-Eeh-AH, Oh shit, OOH, GOD!
*asthma* AHHHHHH, I'm gonna DIIIEEE! *asthma*
Well, this ain't good...
*jesus, did you smoke six packs of cigarettes?*
Oh, boy. Oh boy, I'm dead, I'mdeadi'mdead- I'Mdead, I'mdead, oh.... fuck. =.=
WELL, Shit.
Oh, NOW the door's open, Oh GREAT.... (the doors were already open, Mark...)
*doing this again* I really appreciate the voice acting-
No, ah, hey, How about you get... SUCKED! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Get SUCKED!
Mist Dude: "Does your life really mean that much for you?"
Ye-Yes?? "> .>
Mist: "Come on..."
No! >:|
Okay, Well that didn't answer a lot of questions.... *nervous Markimoo noises*
Mist: "You will tire...."
Nooo, I won't...
Mist: "Why are you running?"
Mist: "This didn't work for anyone...."
*uninterested* Uh-huh, okay... Well, I am persistant!
Mist: "I will make you run... Forever..."
Mist: "If you have the chance..."
Uh oh 0.0
ah, man...
Mist: "Human souls are so unreliable."
Mark: Huh! Are they?
Mist: "You will tire..."
Mark: You don't know that!
*asthma* No! No! No, I gotta get to the suck-age!
*smoking menthol*
Oh, God, that's not the suck-age!
*sucky thing turns on*
Nope, THAT'S no good... Okay, well, IIII'm at a loss
SO, there's gotta be a way- I can't jump... There's no way to jump, but I can crawl...
*realization* Eh, ah, ey, OOOOOHHHH- Oh-Oh-oh-Yiss, Yiss....
Well, this is weird...
Mist: "This is why I hate carbon life..."
*cringe*
Mist: "SO overrated."
*sassy Mark activate* Uh, Carbon life is awesome?? We get sex and BOOBs??
And dicks and butts??
What?
I don't know what you said... (neither do I...)
But, I don't like it in all sense-
Mist: "How many life forms have you destroyed for food... and for sport?"
I-I don't- I don't know...? I haven't destroyed all that many- Oh, I'm slow....
Mist: "This artificial food felt so tasty to them"
*cringe*
Mist: "Calm down..."
Mark: No!
Mist: "I won't eat you alive"
Eh? *= *
Mist: "This is not what I do...."
Wha?
*stammering* I-I'm still concerned, cause it seems like you want to kill me! *suffocating* AHHH, fuck.
Mist: "Calm down..."
Mist: "I won't eat you alive"
Mark: Oh! Yiss!
Mist: "This is not what I do..."
Uh-huh, Yeah, tell me more about how you won't eat me alive... *inhale of panic*
*asthma* AH!
Mist: "You will be an easy prey..."
Uh oh...
Uh oh!
Mist: "Is there enough here for you?"
Mist: "Anyone still alive?"
Mark: No!
Mist: "So much effort... but for what?"
Mark: Uh, for surviving and seeing my FAMILY!
Mist: "You aren't welcome to my world..."
Mark: o .o O-Okay??
OH! THAT WAS THE END??? WHET!?
OH-KAAAYYYYYY!!!!!
OH! Oh- Created in 48 hours... Okay!
That was pretty good!
It- It wasn't quite as scary as it could've been,
Uh, It was just this kind of lumbering thing coming after you and taunting you,
Either way, the voice acting was very good, it made it very Ethereal
In like this very intelligent mist form
Don't know why it existed, and I wanted  to know more about it, but this is why, like,
These indie horror games that you find on Game Jolt, they're like a window into what could be
they're a little snippet of potential, and you see something good and you're like
OHH, this is cool! And then you remember; it's made by a small team and it's made in such a short amount of time, and you're just like-
OH, I want MORE! And this is made for an asylum jam, and it's like, there could be more out of this
And I want to see MORE... That's what I get out of these indie horror games- I wanna see more!
You see the talent, and you see what could be...
with these interesting very basic ideas, and when you see potential
It's like it's there, so either way!
Let me know what you think in the comments below, and thank you so much for watching.
And as always, I will see you....
In the next video!
Buh Byeee!